well here's another one
Dimensions big problem now with 80
million baby worms come along they're
all going to get dementia because they
followed the doctor's advice Alzheimer's
disease is a physician caused disease
just like vitamin D3 deficiency is a
physician cause disease erectile
function and menopause or physician
cause diseases
I can tell by your face you're sort of
like what yeah menopause I thought that
was something that well menopause our
grandmother who's been through menopause
in three seconds without one hot flash
now our modern women spend half their
life dealing with it and they go through
three husbands because guys can't stand
it right and so
um basically what it is is they've been
told they got to give up cholesterol
right in their diets well cholesterol is
the raw material for ovaries to make
estrogen progesterone cholesterol is the
basic
raw material to make steroids which make
estrogen progesterone should go on a low
cholesterol diet you get cholesterol
lowering drugs you're going to have
menopausal symptoms to the point where
you're like a flaming idiot right men
will have erectile dysfunction because
testosterone is 95 by weight cholesterol
you want a cholesterol restricted diet
cholesterol learning drugs there's
nobody home anymore right
um
when it comes to Alzheimer's disease
75 of your brain weight is this fatty
installation material called myelin when
you get Allison's disease the myelin
goes away and the naked nerve fibers all
tangled up and it's legendary that nerve
Tangles are the the iconic diagnostic
feature of Alzheimer's disease nerve
Tangles compared to the other three
Classic Dimensions which don't have that
and
this myelin this fatty insulation
material of the brain that makes up 75
of your brain weight is 100 cholesterol
so you're going to
cholesterol-restricted diet take
cholesterol lowering drugs there's
nobody home up here nobody home down
there I mean life is a mess so we've
made a complete system which we call the
mighty 90 and there's like 25 different
ways to get that depending on you know
people have allergies to shellfish or
they've got allergies this and the other
so we've come up with 25 different ways
to cover every known eventuality
are they like liquids or capsules
whatever we've covered all these things
in what we call the mighty 90 we assure
them that they're going to get optimal
in many cases 8 000 times or 16 000
times or thirty thousand times the
minimum data requirement and so we've
learned over 33 years a lot and so we
use a heavy Hammer to take people off of
the
dialysis all the time I get people off
the heart transplant list all the time I
regrow cartilage I I grew a heart muscle
I grow knees I regrow kidneys I make
kidneys function ice reverse mustard
dystrophy in kids
reverse cystic fibrosis in kids
and so
it's very very gratifying